[MUSIC PLAYING]
MUSTAFA SULEYMAN: Good
morning, everybody.
Welcome to the session.
My name is Mustafa.
I'm co-founder of DeepMind.
And this morning, I want to tell
you a little bit about the work
that we've been doing
to use machine learning
and AI to tackle climate change.
So you may be familiar
with our mission.
Our mission is to try
to solve intelligence.
And the core motivation that led
us to set up this mission when
we started the
company in 2010 was
to try to address the
key question "What if we
could distill what makes
us unique and exceptional
as a species--
our minds, our intelligences,
our capacity to be creative,
to plan over
long-term sequences--
to have really
incredible intuition
for discovering insight in
complex social systems?"
What if we could extract
the essence of that
into an algorithmic construct?
Wouldn't it be incredible if
we could use that and take
advantage of parallel
compute, access
to vast amounts
of training data,
and use it to do really
important things in the world?
And so was the
motivation that led us
to architect
solving intelligence
as our core mission.
And I think what's at
stake in the world is
that many of our most
challenging problems
are actually intractably
complex, from science
to macroeconomics
to weather modeling.
We're overwhelmed by the
complexity of the systems
around us.
We've got tons and tons
of data, but trying
to extract insight
from that data
and learn the relationship
between cause and effect
well enough to be able to
make meaningful predictions
in these environments
is becoming
more and more challenging.
So the key question
is "What if we
were able to use
the sorts of systems
that we've been developing and
try and extract new insight,
but actually use that to turn
insight into real action,
to actually affect these
stock social challenges?"
That was our core motivation.
We really need new tools, new
tools that humans control,
that we design to
try and help us
to make sense of the complexity
of the world around us.
And we began quite
a few years ago now
on the old-school
challenge of Atari.
Our first major
breakthrough came in 2015.
For those of you
who don't know--
I'm sure everyone does.
The Atari set of games was the
sort of 100 or so environments
from around the '80s
and '90s, many of which
you'll be familiar with,
from Pong to Space Invaders.
And the challenge
for us is could we
actually take just
the raw environment,
provide purely the
pixels as inputs,
and give them to an agent that
isn't told anything about what
they could do, isn't
given any prior knowledge,
no heuristics,
everything the agent
should learn purely
from scratch.
And all we provide
is simply the goal.
In this case, the
optimization target was score.
Could a single
agent learn to play
all of these games to a
human-level performance
or even above simply
through correlating score
and a rewarding outcome with
the preceding state that
had taken place over
the past interactions
that it had had
playing the game?
And so the key intuition here
is imagine a robot standing
in an arcade with no
sense of what's actually
going on behind the scenes,
no additional information,
but just controlling
the joystick
and looking at the screen.
So here's a little
video to show you
what it was like when
we first set our agent
to play in this environment.
You can see it's randomly
moving left and right to control
the paddle at the bottom.
And most of the
time, it's completely
missing any of
the bricks at all.
After 300 or so
games, the agent seems
to learn this
correlation between score
going up and moving the paddle
preemptively to the right place
to tap the ball into the blocks.
What was really interesting--
after about 500 or so games,
really unexpectedly and very
surprising to many of us
engineers, was
that it discovered
a strategy of tunneling.
If it could just pummel
the ball up the back,
it could get maximum
score with minimum effort.
And this is really interesting
because it was actually
the first time that we got
really concrete intuition
that we were onto something.
Nothing in the system
had been pre-programmed.
There were no heuristics.
None of the engineers were
able to hand-code little tricks
like this one.
But purely through
self-play, the system
discovered new knowledge.
And that is the core
quest of DeepMind.
How can we discover new
insights and new knowledge?
We extended this
a few years later
to tackle the
ancient game of Go.
The incredible thing
about the game of Go
is that enormous complexity
arises from very, very
stunning simplicity.
There are very few rules and
restrictions in the game.
On a 19-by-19 professional
board like this one,
each player of black
and white stones
takes turns to place a single
stone anywhere on the board
where there's no other stone.
And, over time, the objective
is to surround your opponent's
stones and conquer territory in
the way that you can see here.
The incredible
thing about the game
is just with these simple rules,
there are something like 10
to the power of 170 possible
configurations of the board.
So what you're seeing
here is an intuition
of the branching factor.
At every moment, there's a
further few hundred or so
positions.
And that goes on and on and on.
And to try and place that
in some kind of context--
10 to the power of
170 is estimated
to be more atoms than there
are in the known universe,
in every liquid and solid
and gas in this room,
all around us on
our entire planet,
and in the known universe.
More atoms-- or
there are fewer atoms
in the universe than
there are positions that
are possible in the game of Go.
So the traditional methods
of writing handcrafted rules
and heuristics are
clearly not scalable.
Really important intuition,
because many of our world's
most complex challenges
that we would
like to make progress
with have the same kind
of characteristics.
And so, thankfully, we were
successful in playing the world
champion at the time
at the game of Go.
And this was really recognized
as a milestone moment
in the development of AI.
But really
interestingly, Lee Sedol,
who was one of the legends
of the game who we played
originally in Korea
a few years back,
said something very
interesting after the game.
His initial assessment
going in was
that he thought AlphaGo
was based on a probability
calculation and it
was simply a machine.
But when he saw some of
the spectacular moves
that AlphaGo was able to
play, his mind was changed.
"Surely," he said,
"AlphaGo is creative."
The specific move in
reference, he said,
was "creative and beautiful."
And this was really
exciting for us
because, again, it
demonstrated to us
that a system through
self-play, through interacting
with an environment in the
way that we had designed,
could discover new
strategies that
were surprising to even the
very best players in the world.
After AlphaGo, we extended it
to what we called AlphaZero.
Really interesting that
we're able to generalize
AlphaGo to be able to play
any other two-player game.
So we really wanted to resist
the temptation that systems got
really good at specific games.
Clearly, as humans, what
makes us really impressive
is that we can learn
new skills quite quickly
based on our experience
of performing well
in other domains.
So, for example, if you
know how to ride a bicycle,
you're probably going
to do a bit of a better
job on a motorbike,
and you bring
that prior knowledge to bear.
That transfer learning
approach is exactly what
we were hungering after.
And so we tested
AlphaGo to extend it
to a whole bunch of other games.
Again, learning completely from
scratch in a fully general way,
with no opening book,
no end-game database,
no heuristics.
Its self-play starts completely
from random and no reference
to any past human games,
so purely organically.
And the interesting thing
is that the improvement
rate of the algorithm
was actually phenomenal.
So AlphaGo Zero had
no prior knowledge
of the game and only
the very basic rules
at its input at 0 days.
Three days later, AlphaGo
Zero surpassed the abilities
of AlphaGo Lee, which
is the version that
beat the world champion, Lee
Sedol, four games out of five
in 2015.
And three weeks after
that, AlphaGo Zero
reaches the level of
an AlphaGo Master,
the version that defeated
60 top professionals online
and the world champion,
Ke Jie, in three
out of three games in 2017.
And then after 40
days, AlphaGo Zero
surpassed all other versions
of AlphaGo and arguably
became the best Go
programmer in the world.
And, again, the
key intuition here
is that more training
time, more self-play,
provides the algorithm
and the agent
with more experience, more
examples to learn from,
a greater distribution
of possible state spaces.
And in doing so, it's able
to produce much more general,
much more flexible insights.
So this single system,
this general model
was able to beat the
best systems out there
in Shogi, in chess
in under four hours,
and, ultimately, in Go
in under eight hours.
It's really interesting
here to look at a quote
from Garry Kasparov, one of the
former world chess champions.
He said, "The
implications go far
belong beyond my
beloved chess board.
Not only do these
self-taught expert machines
perform incredibly well,
but we can actually
learn from the new
knowledge they produce."
And, again, this is precisely
the symbiotic man and machine
relationship that we
were hungering after.
How could agent
systems provide us
humans with new insights
and new knowledge
that we could then
use to take actions
in our own complex environments
and, again, train systems
to improve in the process?
And I really want to
sort take a moment
to step back, because
this is really
the real purpose behind our core
mission to solve intelligence.
How can we enable
machines to help teach us
new insights, new
strategies, and new knowledge
to focus first and foremost
on the problems that actually
matter in the world today?
And I think what's really at
heart here is our free choice
to work on the problems that
really matter and really
address the core
question of what is
our purpose in the world today?
And there couldn't be
any greater moment for us
to address these real,
stark social challenges.
For example, take the
challenge of climate change.
We know that global mean surface
temperature over the last 150
years or so has
been rapidly rising.
We know that we're
potentially on a trajectory
to hit 2 degrees of
rising temperature, which
could cause irreversible
consequences for our world
and have a massive
impact on our ecosystems.
According to NASA, the planet's
average surface temperature
has already risen by about 0.9
degrees since the 19th century.
I mean, this is scientific
fact and is clearly
one of the most urgent and
pressing problems for us
to focus on because
the trajectory looks
really worrying.
A 1.5 degrees
centigrade average rise
could put up to 30% of
species at risk of extinction,
according to the IPCC.
And at 2 degrees
centigrade, most
think ecosystems will struggle
to survive altogether.
But this temperature
rise, of course,
doesn't just affect
animals and ecosystems.
Global temperature
increases of 3 degrees
are estimated to result in 330
million people being displaced
by flooding alone,
according to the UN.
And, in fact, this actually
affects all of us right now.
Where we're stood here today,
sea levels could rise by 3 foot
by 2100.
And so take a look at what
would happen right here at IO.
This would leave us underwater
right where we're stood--
pretty remarkable.
So it's clear that climate is
one of our greatest challenges.
And so three or
four years ago, we
decided to ask ourselves the
core question "How could we
as a team start to
focus significant amount
of our efforts on this
really important problem?"
And, of course,
energy consumption
is one of the largest
contributors to climate change
itself.
So we gave ourselves two core
pillars to work on at Google.
The first is the question of
whether we can dramatically
increase the efficiency
of existing systems,
both on the consumer
side and also
on the large-scale industrial
systems side of things.
Secondly, could we rapidly
accelerate the introduction
of renewables?
We know that this
technology is possible.
Prices are plummeting.
But there are some very
significant barriers
to adoption that we
think machine learning
models can help with.
So I'm going to talk to
you about these two goals.
So, first of all, what did
we do on the consumer side?
Well, we've had an excellent
collaboration with the Android
team for over three years now.
And what we've been trying to
do is extend the battery life
that you get from your
phone, simply by improving
the way that your phone
interacts with you in a very
personalized way.
We managed to deliver a 30%
reduction in CPU wake-ups.
This is now rolled
out to Android Pie,
which is already hitting
about 2.5 billion users.
This had an enormous
contribution
to increasing the
overall battery
life from a single charge on a
Pixel to around 30 hours or so.
So this is a little
bit on how it worked.
We basically, along
with the Android team,
built a two-layer deep
convolutional neural network
with a neural network
on top of that
to predict the probability
that an app would
be opened at a given interval.
So the key thing here is
that we abstracted out
an anonymized sequences
of app interactions
that you had and then tried
to predict when you were
likely to use an app in
relation to the other apps
that you were using
in the future.
So we know, for example,
that some people tend
to use certain apps
in the morning,
say, when you're on your
commute or when you're quickly
accessing your news.
Other apps tend to be
used more at the weekends.
And this relationship
is really important
because if we can
optimize which apps
they open in the
background, we can obviously
significantly reduce the
cost on battery life.
And, of course, as with
all of the applications
and deployments and launches
that we try to make,
we pay a great deal of attention
to fairness and privacy.
So there's no favoritism
of one app over another.
All of that was
completely identified.
You may use a particular app in
a very different way to the way
I use another app, and
that doesn't actually
get factored in at all.
It's entirely personalized,
and your individual usage
is what really matters.
But, of course, we personalize
in a privacy-preserving way,
as well, so all of the
personally identifiable data
is removed before the
actual model is trained.
And then the model is retrained
on your local device, which
I think is a really exciting
and promising proof point of how
we're going to get closer
and closer to locally trained
models over the next
five years or so.
So moving now from
processes in your pocket
to processes in the cloud--
of course, at
Google, we have some
of the largest and
actually already
most well-engineered
and efficient
industrial systems in the world.
When we decided to take a
look at Google data centers,
I can tell you that some
of the expert engineers who
had been working on these
systems for almost two decades
now were a little
bit surprised that we
thought we could make them
significantly more efficient.
They were very collaborative,
and we set about
on a three-year
journey to see if we
could try to use machine
learning systems to improve
the efficiency of how power
is managed in the Google data
center fleet.
And this is a super
important problem
because we're all
consuming a hell of a lot
more of data centers'
energy and storage,
and we're creating
vast amounts more data.
Data centers across the
world actually use around 3%
of the world's electricity.
And, of course, it's
growing rapidly,
so there's enormous
opportunity for us
here to try and use the existing
data and the existing systems
and run them much
more efficiently.
And it turns out that the
cooling energy is actually
one of the biggest
consumers of electricity
after the non-server
load in a data center.
In fact, cooling
can actually make up
around 40% of the total energy
used in the data centers.
So how did we do this?
Well, obviously, everything
starts with a large amount
of historic training
data to give the agent,
to give the system
some visibility on how
the system has
operated in the past
and try and learn from that
and replicate it going forward.
So there's over
2,500 data inputs,
again, showing one of the
many benefits of collecting
really rich, really accurate,
ready well-labeled data
over extended periods of time.
We were able to look at
things like the incoming IT
load, power meters, pressure
sensors, water flow meters,
pump and fan speeds, alarms,
external weather conditions--
loads of very rich,
contextual data
that provides the agent
with a lot of information
about how the
system has operated.
And then we asked
the agent to take
control of 20 or so actions.
So it could adjust which
cooling towers are activated.
It could adjust
how many chillers
are being used at what time.
It could adjust pressure set
points, temperature set points,
flow set points--
a whole range of other
control space actions.
And so the way to think about
it a little bit like Atari
is that the system
is trying to learn
the correlation between
data at a particular state
and a desired action
that it's trying
to optimize with respect
to a specific goal.
And, of course, that goal was
can we run the existing system
with the same level
of performance--
we obviously don't
want any drop out
in DC uptime and availability.
But can we do so with
less energy consumed?
And so the way the initial
version of the system worked
is that every five minutes, the
cloud-based agent pulls data
from some of these
thousands of sensors,
does a bunch of cleaning
and processing in the cloud,
and then spits back a
set of recommendations
to a human operator who examines
them and then implements them.
And this adjusts controls
for all the set points
that I mentioned.
And remarkably, this was able to
deliver a 40% reduction in data
center cooling energy.
This is a graph that
we first produced
when we turned on the
machine learning model
for about 48 hours and then
turned it off afterwards.
And again, this was an
incredibly significant moment
for us a couple of years
ago because it was actually
demonstrating that we can
do what we attempted to do,
what we wanted to do
in 2010 when we founded
the company, which is
train in a petri dish, toy,
game-like environment,
and actually
extract the lessons
from that environment
and deploy them in a real
world-- in this case,
in an enormous, very valuable
industrial system like Google's
data center fleet.
But the really
exciting thing is some
of the kinds of
lessons or knowledge
that was discovered
in the process that
was surprising to many of
the data center engineers.
The first is that it is actually
more efficient to spread load
across more equipment.
And so if you think about it
as a data center engineer,
you're having to review
thousands of data sensor inputs
over time, and you've
got all sorts of controls
that you can adapt.
And finding the
optimal relationship
between different pieces
of cooling equipment
at different times given
different incoming IT loads
and different
weather environments
is incredibly difficult, even
for the most experienced data
center engineers.
And so it turned out
that spreading that load
across more equipment was
actually more effective.
Another surprising intuition
that higher flow rate
through the chillers was
actually not always better.
In some cases, it
remained better.
But in many cases, it
was actually better
to reduce flow to the chillers
given some weather conditions.
And, finally, adapting the
loads to different pieces
of equipment across
the year turned out
to also be a very valuable
way to drive efficiencies.
So, then, how did we scale this
up and get it into production
across the fleet?
Well, it was obviously
really important
that we took a safety-first
automation approach.
So let me tell you a
little bit about that.
The first part of the process
looked exactly the same.
The data center produces a
bunch of sensor information
that describes state
at any given moment.
And then the model produces
a set of recommendations.
But in this case, the model
sent those recommendations
to a local data center control
system that automatically
implemented those without
the human necessarily
being in the loop.
And this in itself was the
first autonomous application
that we're aware of in a
large-scale industrial system.
So some of those key
safety features-- firstly,
there was continuous monitoring
across the entire fleet.
There was automatic failover.
Just in case
anything went wrong,
there were a set of smooth
transition heuristics
that allowed the system
to gracefully fail rather
than abruptly shift to
a set of new parameters.
There was two-layer
verification, so
both at the local level
and at the cloud level.
There was verification of
the inputs at both levels.
Constant communication between
the data center operator,
the model, the cloud team, and
the local data center team,
too.
And then, crucially, there
was uncertainty estimation.
And I think this
is very exciting.
It's the beginnings of
interpretability of our machine
learning algorithms.
You want your model
to accurately give you
a confidence indicator
of how sure it
is that a particular
set of recommendations
are going to lead to a
particular outcome that
is desirable.
And sometimes you might
have a bit more courage
to move that confidence
estimation further
towards the objective
that you're looking
for if you choose to do that.
Or you might want to
keep it more constrained,
depending on what
you're optimizing for
and how risky the state
is at that moment.
And, of course, there's
always rules and heuristics,
and the human is in the
loop all of the time.
The interesting thing here is
that over the 12-month period
that our autonomous
system was in deployment,
as more and more data or
training examples were
collected, the
performance of the system
got better and
better and better.
In this case, going down
is actually a good thing
because it's improving the
efficiency of the system
and using less energy to deliver
the same performance output.
So it's really cool to
see one of the key data
center engineers in the
team say the following.
"It was amazing to
see the AI learn
to take advantage
of winter conditions
and produce colder than
normal water, which
reduces the energy required for
cooling with the data center."
So really helpful to
get that feedback.
So now moving on to what we've
been doing on the wind farm
side of things.
This was the second
pillar of our motivation
to try to figure out how
we can use machine learning
models to make wind
much more competitive.
The challenge with
wind energy is
that although the
cost of production
can by unit be
lower, over a year,
it's really, really
difficult, principally
because it's very unlike
fossil fuel energy
and it's very
difficult to dispatch.
It's very unreliable.
So grid operators
really prioritize
knowing exactly how
much energy they're
going to receive from
different producers
and when they need
to dispatch that
to the various
different consumers
who demand it at
a particular time.
And this has really significant
economic consequences,
because that certainty
is incredibly valuable.
The unpredictability
of renewable energy
makes it much, much less
valuable than fossil fuels
because you can't
guarantee the exact amount.
Sometimes it's windy.
Sometimes it's not.
There's huge variability.
So our challenge was
to try to improve
the quality of our predictions
so that we could accurately
schedule when we were going
to have surplus wind energy
to provide to the grid.
And that makes it
much more competitive
with traditional fossil
fuel energy production.
We started working on about 700
megawatts of Google's wind farm
portfolio.
This is about a quarter of
the entire energy produced
by Google at any given time.
And just to put
that in perspective,
it's about the same
amount of energy
that's consumed in
all of San Francisco,
so it's really material.
And, again, the
way that it worked
is that we took a
whole set of inputs,
including a whole range
of weather forecasts,
local weather observations, and
all sorts of other data inputs,
and we trained
the neural network
to try to predict with some
probability distribution what
power generation will
look like in 36 hours.
And that allowed the team
to then provide the grid
with much more accurate,
much more reliable
information about when the farms
were able to provide energy
back to the grid,
and therefore keep
it competitive with the
rest of fossil fuels.
Just to give you a bit of an
intuition for how difficult
this is, this is production
from 0 to 250 megawatts,
as you can see on
the y-axis here,
and that's just across
a 16-day period.
So the scale of the variation
is absolutely phenomenal.
So it's really difficult to
make this a competitive product.
And being able to tell the grid
that we're very confident in 36
hours that we're going
to be able to supply you
with the right amount
of energy that you need,
again, makes it competitive.
And you can see here that
our predictions are tracking
the ground truth over time.
Overall, this actually made
the value of the wind energy
that's developed at
Google 20% more valuable
in economic terms.
And so, again, this is a
step change improvement,
a really significant
step up that
helps us to eliminate fossil
fuels in the grid over time
and increase the amount
of non-carbon-based energy
that we're producing.
So, finally, just to sort
of wrap up and summarize,
the intuition I want to
leave everybody with today
is that we actually
have enormous potential
to deliver radical improvement
to existing systems.
Of course, we
would love a moment
where we can rebuild
everything from scratch.
But the reality is, we have
to engage over the next couple
decades with old-school,
industrial, established
systems, where we have to work
with existing data and existing
hardware and existing
infrastructure.
There were no new phones
used in the production
of these algorithms,
no new cooling
systems, no new turbines.
This was existing hardware.
But when we collect
the right data,
and it's stored and processed
and well labeled accurately,
we actually can deploy
machine learning models
to generate enormous
step-function-like
efficiencies.
And I think this is a
very modest step forward
in the right
direction and gives us
a good sign that
over the next decade,
I think there could be really
remarkable breakthroughs
and advances to come from these
kinds of energy efficiencies
using machine learning models.
So with that, I just
want to leave you
with a final closing thought.
This, to me, is the
real power of AI--
to help us find really
deeply practical,
real-world solutions
to try and tame some
of the complexity of our most
difficult social challenges.
This is our core purpose.
And, to me, this is what
makes life worth living.
Thanks very much for
listening to our talk.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]